Mi abuelo me dijo cuando era niña
Si dices suficientemente una palabra, se convierte en tu esencia.
Y puesto que me crié en una ciudad segregada, Baltimore, Maryland,
de cierta manera uso aquella idea de viajar por toda América con una grabadora
gracias a Dios por la tecnología --
para entrevistar a la gente, pensando que si yo caminara en sus palabras --
lo cual también explica por qué no llevo zapatos cuando actúo
si caminara en sus palabras, que de alguna manera, podría absorber los Estados Unidos
También me inspiró Walt Whitman
quien quiso absorber su país y estar absorto en ello.
Así que estos cuatro personajes vienen de la obra
a la cual me he dedicado durante muchos años
y mucho más de – no sé—unas dos mil personas
a las cuales he entrevistado.
¿Hay alguien aquí que tenga edad para conocer a Studs Terkel, aquel viejo hombre de la radio?
A mí me pareció la persona ideal
a quien recurrir para subrayar un momento destacable en la historia norteamericana.
Saben que "nació en 1912, el año en que se hundió el Titanic
el buque más grande que jamás se construyó. Se atropella con la punta de un iceberg,
y ¡pam! se hundió. Se hundió, y surgí yo. ¡Ay, qué siglo!
(Risa)
Les doy su respuesta acerca de un momento destacable en la historia norteamericana.
Momento destacable en la historia norteamericana, no creo que haya solo uno;
No se puede decir que fue Hiroshima, pero es muy importante - -
No puedo pensar en un solo momento que para mí es el más significativo.
La disminución gradual- me parece que disminución es la palabra
que utiliza la gente de Watergate, la disminución de la moralidad- -
es un proceso paulatino, que se compone de muchas etapas.
Ven ustedes, que ahora también tenemos la tecnología
la cual, según mi modo de ver, disminuye cada vez más el toque humano
Ah, déjenme contarles una historia graciosa..
El aeropuerto de Atlanta es moderno,
y deberían dejar la puerta allí.
Estos trenes que te traen a una explanada y continúan hacia un destino.
Y estos trenes son cómodos,
y silenciosos y eficaces.
Y escuchas una voz en el tren, una voz humana.
En los viejos tiempos, había robots, los robots imitaban a los seres humanos.
Ahora son los seres humanos que imitan a los robots.
La voz dice: Primera Explanada: Omaha, Lincoln.
Segunda Explanada: Dallas, Fort Worth. Es la misma voz.
Y justo cuando el tren está por salir, una pareja joven se apura por entrar
y el personal está por cerrar las puertas neumáticas
Y esa voz dice, sin vacilar,
"A causa de la entrada tarde, tenemos una demora de 30 segundos."
Y en ese momento, todo el mundo se dirige a la pareja y da rienda suelta a su mirada odiosa,
y la pareja hace así, saben, retroceden ante ellos .
Bueno, por casualidad, tomé unos traguitos antes de embarcarme al tren - -
Lo hago para armarme de valor para hacer el viaje- - así que
Imito un silbido de tren, con la mano en el --
“George Orwell, ha venido la hora de tu muerte,” ven.
Bueno, algunos de ustedes se ríen. Todo el mundo se ríe
cuando cuento ese chiste, pero no en este tren. Silencio.
De repente todo el mundo me está mirando.
Aquí estoy con la pareja, los tres
retrocediéndonos al pie de caballería, al punto de morir, saben.
En ese momento veo un bebé, un recién nacido, en el regazo de su madre
Yo sé que el bebé es hispano, porque la madre habla con su compañero en español.
Decido hablar con el bebé. Le digo
con la mano en la boca porque mi aliento debe de oler al alcohol,
Le digo al bebé, “Señor o Señora,
¿cuál es su opinión considerada de la raza humana?
Y el bebé me mira, saben, a la manera de los bebés, como si comprendiera todo lo que yo decía,
se pone a reír,
se parte de esta risa loca.
Yo digo, “Gracias a Dios por la reacción humana. Aún no estamos perdidos.”
Pero ven que el toque humano desaparece.
Tenemos que cuestionar la verdad oficial.
¿Saben qué es lo que tiene de grandioso Mark Twain?
saben que honramos a Mark Twain pero no leemos su obra.
Claro que leemos Huck Finn, por supuesto que leemos Huck Finn claro.
Quiero decir, que Huck, por supuesto, era tremendo.
¿Se acuerdan de aquella fantástica escena en la balsa? ¿Se acuerdan de lo que hizo Huck?
Ven que tenemos a Huck, es un muchacho analfabeto, que falta de educación
pero hay algo dentro de su espíritu.
Y la verdad oficial, la verdad era que, la ley era que
un negro era propiedad, era una cosa, ven ustedes.
Y Huck se embarca en la balsa con una propiedad que se lllama Jim, un esclavo,
Y Huck oye que Jim va a tomar a su esposa y a sus niños
y los va a robar de la mujer que es su dueña,
Y Huck dice “Ay, Dios mío, ay, Díos mío - -
esa mujer, esa mujer nunca hizo daño a nadie..
Ay, los va a robar, los va a robar,
va a hacer una cosa terrible."
En ese momento dos negreros los alcanzaron, persiguiendo a esclavos, persiguiendo a Jim.
“¿Alguien está en la balsa con usted?” le preguntan a Huck. Y Huck les responde. “Sí.”
“¿Es blanco o negro?” “Blanco.” Y los esclavistas desaparecen.
Y Huck dijo, “Ay, Dios mío, Dios mío, mentí, mentí, ay,
Hice una cosa terrible, muy terrible, ¿por qué me siento bien?”
Pero es la bondad de Huck, su buen corazón
ven que todo se ha reprimido.
Asi que el toque humano está desapareciendo.
Entonces me preguntan subrayar un momento destacable
A mí no me parece que haya solo uno en la historia norteamericana
Al contrario es una colección de momentos que nos traen a la actualidad,
En que las banalidades se convierten en las noticias.
Y cada vez más se disminuye la consciencia del dolor o del otro.
Así es. Saben que, no sé si esto les será útil o no,
pero citaba a Wright Morris, un escritor de Nebraska que dice que,
nos interesan cada vez más las comunicaciones
mientras que la comunicación en sí empieza a aburrirnos.
Bueno, chicos, tengo que largarme de aquí, tengo cita con el cardiólogo.
Y ahí lo tienen, Studs Terkel.
(Aplausos)
Hablando de correr riesgos. Voy a representar a alguien que no le gusta a nadie.
Saben que a la mayoría de actores nos gusta representar personajes simpáticos.
bueno, no siempre, pero es la idea, especialmente en una conferencia de este tipo,
me gusta inspirar a la gente.
Pero ya que esta conferencia llevaba el título de correr riesgos
voy a representar a alguien a la cual nunca he representado antes porque es tan antipática
que de hecho, una persona fue entre bastidores
y me dijo que debería sacarla del espectáculo.
Sin embargo sigo representándola porque según mi modo de ver en una conferencia de este tipo
deberíamos conceptualizar el riesgo como algo bueno.
Pero hay ciertas connotaciones diferentes de la palabra riesgo
y lo mismo pasa con la palabra naturaleza. ¿Qué es la naturaleza?
Maxine Greene, quien es una filósofa maravillosa
quien tiene tantos años como Studs y era la cabeza de una filosofía
una gran organización tipo filosófico
La visité un día y le pregunté cuáles son las dos cosas
que ella no sabe, pero que todavía quiere saber.
Y me dijo, “Yo, personalmente, todavía me siento obligada a hacer reverencias
cuando veo al presidente de mi universidad.
Y todavía me siento obligada a salir a comprar café
para mis colegas masculinos, aunque soy mayor que muchos de ellos.”
Y me dijo,”Intelectualmente,
ya no tengo suficientes conocimientos de la imaginación negativa
Y seguro que el 11 de Septiembre nos enseñó
que ése es un área que no hemos investigado
Así que este monólogo trata de la imaginación negativa
Nos hace plantearnos preguntas acerca de lo que es la naturaleza y de lo que es la Madre Naturaleza,
y de lo que quiere decir la palabra riesgo.
Escribí este monólogo en el Instituto Correccional para Mujeres de Maryland
Todo esto viene al pie de la letra de una cinta.
Y bautizo las cosas porque pienso que la gente habla en poemas orgánicos.
este monólogo se llama “Un Espejo en Su Boca.”
La persona que habla es una presa que se llama Pauline Jenkins.
“Empecé a aprender cómo esconderlo,
porque no quería que nadie supiera que estaba pasando en mi casa
Quiero que todo el mundo piense en nosotros como una familia normal.
Quero decir que no nos faltaba nada,
pero este hecho no disminuyó el dolor de mis hijos
eso no remitió sus temores.
Se me acabaron las excusas para los ojos morados
y los labios partidos y los moretones. Ya no tenía más excusas.
Y me golpeó también. Pero eso no cambió el hecho de que
era una pesadilla para mi familia, era una pesadilla.
Y les fallé terriblemente
porque yo le permitía continuar.
Pero la noche en que mató a Myesha
y con cada día la intensidad se aumentó
hasta que una noche regresamos a casa después de comprar drogas
y se enfadó con Myesha, y se puso a golpearla
y la puso en una tina. Utilizaría un cinturón.
Tenía un cinturón porque tenía la retorcida y pervertida idea de que
Myesha tenía relaciones sexuales con su hermano menor.
y se acariciaban – así lo explicaba él.
Estoy hablando justamente de la noche en que murió Myesha.
Entonces la puso en la tina,
Y yo estaba en el cuarto con el bebé.
Y cuatro meses antes de este incidente, cuatro meses antes de que muriera Myesha,
Tenía la idea de que podía arreglar este hombre. Entonces tuve un bebé con él. --Loca--.
Pensando que si le daba su propio hijo, dejaría la mía en paz.
Y no funcionó, no funcionó.
Y acabé con tres hijos, Houston, Myesha, y Dominic,
quien tenía cuatro meses cuando me metieron presa.
Y yo estaba en el cuarto. Como ya he dicho, él la tenía en la sala de baño
Y él - - él - - cada vez que la golpeaba, ella caía.
Y se golpeaba la cabeza en la tina. Ocurría continuamente, repetidamente.
Podía oírlo, pero no me atreví a moverme. No me moví.
Ni siquiera para averiguar lo que estaba pasando.
Simplemente me quedé sentada ahí y escuchaba..
Entonces él la puso en el vestíbulo.
Le dijo, siéntate ahí. Entonces se quedó sentada ahí por cuatro o cinco horas.
Y luego él le dijo, levántate.
Y cuando se levantó, dijo que no podía ver.
Su cara estaba magullada. Tenía el ojo morado.
Toda su cabeza estaba hinchada;
Su cabeza estaba hinchada al doble del tamaño normal.
Le dije, déjala dormir. La dejó dormir.
A la mañana siguiente había muerto.
Él entró en su cuarto para ver si estaba lista para ir a la escuela, y se puso muy agitado.
Dijo que no respiraba.
Yo supe de inmediato que había muerto.
Ni siquiera quería aceptar el hecho de su muerte, así que entré en su cuarto
y le puse un espejo en la boca --
No salía nada, nada, de su boca.
Él dijo, él dijo, él dijo,
no podemos, no podemos, dejar que nadie descubra esto.
Dice, tienes que ayudarme. Digo que sí. Digo que sí.
A fin de cuentas, he guardado un secreto durante tantos años
así que me pera natural seguir guardando secretos.
Entonces fuimos a un centro comercial y le dijimos a un policía que la habíamos perdido
que ella había desaparecido.
Le dijimos a un guardia de seguridad que ella había desaparecido;
aunque sabíamos que ese no era el caso
Y le describimos uno de sus conjuntos al guardia
Y regresamos a casa y le pusimos la misma ropa que acabamos de describir
la ropa que le habíamos dicho al guardia que llevaba
Y después levantamos al bebe y a mi otro hijo,
y condujimos hacia I-95.
Estaba muerta de miedo, y tan paralizada,
no podía más que mirar en el espejo retrovisor.
Y él la dejó en el arcén de la autopista.
Mi propia hija, dejé que esto le pasara.
Ahí lo tienen, una investigación de la imaginación negativa.
(Aplausos)
Cuando emprendí este proyecto
que se llama En El Camino: En Búsqueda de un Personaje Norteamericano
con mi grabadora, pensé que iba a viajar por Norteamérica
y encontrarla con todos sus aspectos -- jinetes de rodeo, vaqueros, ganaderos de cerdos,
cachiporreras -- pero medio me atascaron las relaciones interraciales,
porque mi primer gran espectáculo trataba de un disturbio provocado por asuntos de raza.
Entonces fui a ambos -- dos disturbios de este tipo,
uno de ellos era el disturbio de Los Ángeles. Y el monólogo que sigue se inspira de esa experiencia.
Porque este monólogo es lo que yo diría
He aprendido la mayoría de lo que sé de las relaciones interraciales de este monólogo.
Es una especie de aria, yo diría, y está en muchas de mis cintas.
Todo el mundo sabe que ocurrieron los disturbios de Los Ángeles
porque cuatro polis golpearon a un negro que se llamaba Rodney King.
Lo grabaron en cinta – la tecnología --
y lo mostraron en las noticias en todos los hogares del mundo
Todos pensaban que meterían presos a los cuatro polis.
Pero no lo hicieron, y de ahí los disturbios .
Y muncha gente se olvida de que había un segundo juicio,
de acuerdo con la petición de George Bush padre
Y el resultado del juicio era que metieron a dos de los polis en prisión
y los otros dos eran inocentes. Yo estaba en el juicio
Y recuerdo que todo el mundo bailaba en la calle
porque tenían miedo de que habría otro disturbio
Había una explosión de alegría a causa del veredicto.
Había una comunidad que no compartía la alegría – los coreanoestadounidenses,
cuyas tiendas se habían quemado hasta los cimientos.
Así que esta mujer, la señora Young Soon-Han,
Supongo que fue ella la que me enseñó la mayoría de lo que sé de la raza.
Y ella también plantea una pregunta que también explora Studs:
este concepto de la verdad oficial, de cuestionar la verdad oficial.
Entonces, lo que está cuestionando aquí, está corriendo un riesgo
al cuestionar lo que es la justicia en la sociedad.
Y esto se llama, “Tragándome la Amargura.”
Solía pensar que los Estados Unidos de América era el mejor país del mundo
En Corea veía muchas películas norteamericanas que retraban el lujoso estilo de vida de Hollywood.
Nunca veía ningún hombre pobre, ni ningún negro.
Hasta 1992, pensaba que Norteamérica era el mejor país del mundo, todavía creo que lo es
Eso no lo niego por ser víctima.
Pero a finales de ’92, cuando estábamos tan confundidos,
Y teníamos todos los problemas financieros y todos los problemas de salud mental,
empecé a darme cuenta de que en realidad los Coreanos
somos totalmente excluidos de la sociedad y no somos nada.
¿Por qué? ¿Por qué tienen que excluirnos?
No teníamos derecho al tratamiento médico, ni a cupones de alimento, ni a GR,
ni asistencia social, nada. Muchos norteamericanos de origen africano que nunca trabajan
recibieron la subvención minima para sobrevivir.
No recibimos nada porque tenemos coche y casa.
Y pagamos impuestos muy altos. ¿Dónde está la justicia?
OK. OK. OK. OK.
Probablemente muchos norteamericanos de origen africano creen que han ganado con el juicio.
Me quedé aquí sentada mirándolos la mañana después del veredicto
Y todo el día había fiestas, celebraban,
todo South Central, todas las iglesias. Y dicen,
bueno, finalmente se ha hecho la justicia en esta sociedad,
¿Y qué pasa con los derechos de las víctimas?
Consiguieron sus derechos al destruir a inocentes comerciantes Coreanos.
Como yo, respetan mucho al Dr. Martin King.
Es el único modelo que tiene la comunidad negra; no me importa nada Jesse Jackson.
Es el modelo de la no violencia, la no violencia --
y a todos les gustaría estar en su espíritu.
¿Pero qué pasó en 1992? Destruyeron a personas inocentes.
Y me pregunto si esto es en realidad lo que significa la justicia
para ellos, conseguir sus derechos de esa manera.
Me tragaba la amargura, sentada aquí, mirándolos.
Parecían divertidísimos, pero me alegraba por ellos
Me alegraba de verdad por ellos. Por lo menos habían logrado algo, OK.
Olvidémonos de las víctimas Coreanas y de las otras víctimas
que fueron destruidas por ellos.
Luchan por conseguir sus derechos durante más de dos siglos
y tal vez porque sacrifiquen a otras minorías culturales,
La gente hispana y asiática sufriríamos más en la cultura dominante.
Por eso comprendo,
Por eso tengo sentimientos encontrados sobre el veredicto.
Pero me gustaría, me gustaría, me gustaría
compartir el placer con ellos.
Ojalá pudiera convivir con los negros.
Pero tras los disturbios, la brecha entre nostros es demasiado grande.
El incendio arde todavía. ¿Cómo se dice? [Poco claro]
Encendiéndose, encendiéndose, prendiendo fuego. Prendiendo fuego.
Está todavía. Podría estallar en llamas en cualquier momento.
La señora Young-Soon Han.
(Aplausos)
La otra razón por la cual nunca llevo zapatos
es por si acaso tengo ganas de acurrucarme
e imaginarme en los pies de otra persona,
o estando de verdad en el lugar de otra persona.
Y les dije que en el año -- ¿saben qué? no les precisé el año,
pero en el 79 pensé que iba a investigar al Personaje Norteamericano
y encontrar a monta-toros y granjeros de cerdos y tipos así,
y me atascaron las relaciones interraciales.
Finalmente, sí encontré a un torero, hace dos años.
Y he ido con él a los rodeos, y hemos establecido vínculos afectivos.
Y él tiene el papel principal en un artículo de opinión que hice acerca del Congreso Republicano,
Él es Republicano--No diré nada sobre my afiliación a algún partido, pero de cualquier manera---
Les doy a mi querido amigo Brent Williams,
y este monólogo trata de la tenacidad,
por si acaso alguien necesita saber lo que significa ser tenaz
en el contexto en el que trabaja. Creo que hay una lección a aprender en este monólogo.
Y esto se llama "La Tenacidad",
Bueno, soy optimista. Quero decir fundamentalmente optimista.
Bueno, saben, bueno, es como mi esposa, Jolene.
su familia siempre le dice,
¿Jamás has pensado que él nació un fracasado?
Parece que tiene tanta mala suerte, ¿no crees>
Pero cuando ese toro pasó en mi riñón, sabes,
No perdí el riñón—hubiera perdido el riñón,
Todavía tengo el riñón, así que no me parece que soy un fracasado total.
Me parece que es buena suerte.
(Risa)
Y saben ustedes, esto pasa
Estaba en la consulta del doctor, la última vez que me tomaron un TAC
y había una revista Reader's Digest en la sala de espera, de octubre 2002
Había un artículo que se llamaba algo así con “Siete maneras de salir con suerte”. Y dice
si quieres salir con suerte,
tienes que rodearte de optimistas.
Bueno, hasta cuando le dije a mi esposa que quieres reunirte aquí conmigo
para charlar conmigo, ella me dijo, es habladora,
es buena contigo. No va a hacer nada.
Y luego me llamaste y me dijiste que querías viajar a mi rincón del mundo
para entrevistarme y mi esposa fue a buscarte en el Internet.
Me dijo, mira quién es.
Ni siquiera vas a poder contestarle las preguntas.
(Risa)
Y estaba diciendo, Pensará que soy idiota
porque nunca he ido a la universidad,
y no hablaría de manera profesional ni nada por el estilo.
Le dije, mira, esa mujer me habló durante horas.
¿Sabes que? Si no le hablara – era como si
quisiera que siguiera hablando, ¿me explico?
Ni siquiera creo que ella vendría a visitarnos.
¿La confianza? Bueno, creo que me motiva
más la determinación que la confianza
Según mi modo de ver la confianza es como,
has estado en la espalda del toro antes de darte cuenta de que puedes montarlo.
En cierta medida tener confianza es como ser arrogante, pero de buena manera.
Pero la determinación, es como, "Al diablo con la forma,
tú agarra el cuerno"
(Risa)
Es Tuff Hederman, en la película Ocho segundos.
Bueno, como siempre decía Pat O’Mealey cuando era chico,
dice, ¿sabes qué? Te esfuerzas más que cualquier muchacho que he conocido.
Y el esfuerzo y la determinación son iguales.
La determinación es como, vas a sostenerte con el toro
aunque lo montes boca abajo.
La determinación es como, vas a montar al toro
hasta que te golpees la cabeza sobre la tierra.
¿Y la Libertad? Sin duda es el rodeo.
¿Y la Belleza? Yo ni sé lo que es la belleza.
Bueno, supongo que tendría que ser el rodeo también.
Mira como somos, estamos en familia,
entre colegas, estrechando las manos y luchando a mi alrededor,
Es como juntar las tarjetas de crédito para pagar las entradas y la gasolina, ¿me explico?
Montamos juntos, comemos juntos
y dormimos juntos.
Ni siquiera puedo imaginar cómo me voy a sentir
la última vez que participe en un rodeo. Bueno, todo irá bien.
Tengo mi Rancho y todo.
pero en realidad ni siquiera quiero pensar en ese día que se acerca
Bueno, supongo que se parecerá mucho a --
Supongo que será como el día en que se murió mi hermano.
¿La tenacidad? Bueno, estábamos en West Jordan Utah, y este toro
me empujó la cara por los brotes metálicos
Me rompió por completo la cara y tuve que ir al hospital
Y tuvieron que coserme y enderezarme la nariz.
Y esa noche tenía planeado un rodeo,
así que no quería que me dieran la anestesia,
o lo que sea. Así que me cosieron la cara.
Y luego tuvieron que enderezarme la nariz,
y tomaron estas varillas y me las empujaron en las narices
y las varillas extendieron hacia mis sesos
y tuve la sensación de que estaba saliendo de mi cabeza,
y todo el mundo decía que debía de haberme matado,
pero sobreviví. Supongo que tolero bien el dolor.
(Risa)
Pero lo bueno era que, una vez que me empujaron estas varillas por ahí
Y me enderezaron la nariz, podía respirar,
y no había podido respirar
desde que me rompí la nariz en el rodeo de la escuela secundaria.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)